all right you too but it is a big day
it is the Dave Rubin 44th birthday
spectacular here on YouTube I haven't
done a livestream for for quite some
time actually between the book and
general craziness and riots and protests
and all sorts of other stuff it's been a
little haywire around here I'm sure it's
been a little haywire wherever you are
too so it's been a while since I've done
one of these but we're gonna do a big
bonanza bonkers livestream for you I'm
answering your questions that are
submitted at Rubin report.com Clyde is
in the studio and he's stepping on the
audio mixer at the moment that might be
problematic as the kids say so we'll
keep an eye on that yeah it looks like
he wants to get out of here guys so we
can get Clyde out maybe he'll come back
a little later but yes it is my birthday
I have 44 years old I'm pretty sure I'm
the oldest person on YouTube
who else is on YouTube that is of that
age you know YouTube is it's for the
kids it's a it's a young man's game but
a lot of people I posted this morning on
on Twitter and on Rubin report com that
it's my 44th birthday a lot of people
saying I look like I'm in my 30s so that
that is nice to hear I'm feeling good
about the hair today that's got a fresh
cut from my girl Jess yesterday went to
her house and she cut me up I don't know
that that's even legal here in
California it's still unclear what's
happening but I'm feeling pretty good
for 44 actually this has been 20/20
despite the the zombie apocalypse and
you know the coronavirus and the riots
of the protests and creeping Marxism and
the Socialists and the communists at all
that's up besides all that it's actually
been a great year I mean think things
are good for us right now the book sales
were great life is good you know it's
summer here in Cali which is always
great and and I'm feeling good about
things I'm actually going out to dinner
tonight with friends for the first time
since this whole thing went down I did
have
a drink once out I had a drink with
Karlin borisenko who's been on the show
a couple weeks ago we went out for a
drink that was very exciting but I'm
actually going to eat a meal
I mean break bread with other human
beings tonight somewhere in an
undisclosed location in Beverly Hills
yeah we're we're fancy people anyway so
I'm gonna be taking your questions Oh
and I wanted to tell you guys I just
posted this on Twitter but I did get
myself a birthday present because you
know these are these are weird times you
don't know if you're gonna be seeing
people you don't know what kind of
presents are gonna be rolling in
although howling my assistant to just go
to the post office and pick up all the
stuff from our PETA box and I've got
like 30 boxes out there things that you
guys are sending me so I thank you in
advance and I'll thank you all
personally after after we opened some
stuff later today
but I did get myself a present I got my
first gun I got a Beretta we just picked
it up it is it's a handgun 9-millimeter
I'm psyched I'm gonna go I know I've had
a ton of people you know offer to take
me shooting and we'll go to arrange and
all that stuff so I'm gonna take a
couple people up on those offers it is
it is our first gun you know this is
obviously something I've been thinking
about I've really been thinking about it
for about two years and then just the
craziness of the last month and
particularly the the riots in LA and
just you know the the insane way the
media and many of our public officials
talked about the police who I completely
stand with the police and I think 99.9%
of them are great people you know trying
to be good public servants and they get
treated horribly and but more than
anything else I mean I wanted the
ability to be able to protect myself
protect myself protect my family protect
my property and the rest of it Clyde
does do a hell of a job he barks at the
gardener but we wanted to take that that
next step so I'm psyched I posted a
picture of it on Twitter which you can
look at right now I'm just holding the
gun I don't even think there was a
magazine clip in the thing but
apparently my finger was on the trigger
which is a big no-no so I thank you guys
for keeping me honest and I saw Jason
Howerton
I believe works at the first now he used
to work at the blaze he's in Texas he's
a big gun guy and he tweeted out the
picture and he said that's not Dave's
fault he's from California let's give
him a little bit of a learning curve
here so I do appreciate that you find
people and I'm gonna take some questions
and really nothing's off-limits it's
been a while since I've been able to
talk to you guys you know the last two
months really
today's June 26 by the way it's also
Derek Jeter's birthday you guys all know
Derek Jeter of course and a little-known
basketball player although one of my
favorite basketball players of all time
although he passed away a few years ago
out of nowhere
young guy Jerome Kersey who was mostly
known for being on the Blazers in the in
the late 80s early 90s was in the finals
a couple times ended up winning a
championship much later in his career
with the the San Antonio Spurs he was a
great player that very few people know
about there's a little side trivia for
you but you know I spent basically all
of May sitting in this chair for like 12
hours a day sometimes even more
sometimes my days started about 4:00
a.m. if I was doing like you know Fox
and friends in New York at like 7:00
a.m. well that's 4 a.m. here so I'd be
up at 3:30 so I'd go to bed at like
10:00 be up at 3:30 do do a hit and then
I'd go to sleep for like two hours and
then have interviews pretty much all day
long just sitting in this chair and I'd
be talking to people literally all over
the world from from South Korea and
Australia and Ireland and the UK and and
just wherever it was Mexico and and
Brazil and Canada it was pretty amazing
but I spent about 6 weeks in my life it
was more than a month about six weeks my
life just sitting in this chair just
talking to people so it was sort of
interesting because when you do these
one after another after another after
another you can really figure out who
the good interviewers are because they
have a way of making it feel freshly
that you don't go into like the usual
talking points which I really tried to
be as present as possible for everybody
and and not do the talking point stuff
but you know if they're asking you about
the book there's only so many ways you
can talk about the same ideas over and
over but it was super fun but you know I
was supposed to be on tour I had a tour
a countrywide tour I think we had about
20 to 25 stops that was going to wrap at
the beginning of June so all of
I was going to be on tour and then we
were gonna work on a UK tour and we were
gonna do some stuff in Canada and a
whole bunch of other stuff so that's
obviously still on hold but I will tour
the book at some point so I'm excited
about that oh and you know what since
it's my birthday and it's just me and
you here I will tell you guys that the
second book is in the works I am
announcing it right now yeah the the
first book obviously was was a huge
success success which is awesome New
York Times bestseller which I know I
know I rail about the New York Times all
the time and then I'm saying with pride
that it's a New York Times bestseller
it's just the way the publishing world
works so I was happy to get on the list
for the publishers and all my guys that
worked so hard on promotion and all that
stuff but it is a little weird to want
sort of approval from something that you
know you don't generally approve of I
get it it is a little weird but but the
book absolutely crushed it sales are
still great and and I think it was
pretty freakin timely for everything
going on you know I probably could have
titled it don't burn the store that this
book is in that might have been a good
one don't burn the target down that you
might be able to pick up this book that
would worked but you know the book the
ideas in the book really are everything
that we're inviting that write about
right now like all of the stuff all the
people that are suddenly waking up and
going oh my god it wasn't just college
students oh my god these ideas these
pervasive nefarious awful ideas that
have just spread their tentacles
throughout Society they didn't just
magically appear one day there were a
bunch of us and I know you guys know
this if you're watching this but it's
like there were about 20 of us online
that have been hitting this thing over
and over and over for the last five
years and people have been sending the
old clips of myself talking about this
stuff like four or five years ago at
public events are on the show or with
guests or whatever and it's like yeah
I'm not surprised about any of it and
that's exactly what the book is about
but enough book promo I'm gonna take
some of your questions and I we're doing
this on Ruben report.com so if you go to
Ruben report com you can submit
questions anything is find nothing is
off-limits it doesn't have to be about
politics hopefully I'm getting some
some life questions here too or you can
ask about music or video games or sports
or whatever or what I'm wearing on my
feet right now
fancy flip-flops that's right and I'm
wearing socks look I know people get
upset you can't wear flip-flops with
socks but I find it oddly comfortable I
don't know if that makes me feel like an
old Russian immigrant or whatever but I
enjoy it and that's what I'm doing there
you go
ok so I'm going to do these in no
particular order we got a gajillion
questions flying in again if you want to
throw a question in that's Ruben
report.com
let's see
Janell well this seems like the right
one for a for a birthday any thoughts
feelings advice about this stage of life
being in your 40s I'm interested in how
you feel it compares to your younger
years um you know truly so 44 that feels
there's something about 44 that feels
like very solidly like is that middle
age I guess that's middle age right so
if it's middle if it's smack in the
middle that means 88 this is the end of
the whole ride right now hopefully
eighty eight's actually for these days
if you're if you take care of yourself
and medical science and everything else
like eighty eight's on the young side
and hopefully as time goes on there's
tons of people that are working on life
extension and all that stuff but let's
say somewhere in your 90's is about when
you wrap it up or at least at a at a
functional level interestingly in my
family the women live an incredibly long
time like the I had a great grandma and
I think died at 99 and she had I think
six sisters where she was one of six
sisters and they all lived into their
late 90's and they had cousins all the
women that all lived into their 90's the
men dropped like flies very early what
my my paternal grandfather died when I
was in second grade my maternal
grandfather died when my mom was
pregnant with me I did have one
great-grandfather who made it to his 90s
but the women do really well so
hopefully I got some of that that woman
magic in me but anyway 44 seems kind of
kind of middle middle age it feel
honestly what I feel right now is that
like I'm basically in the prime of my
life like I'm in I'm in the prime like
I'm not quite as quick on the basketball
court as I used to be I do have a torn
ACL that's one thing that happens as you
get older I remember I don't like
bragging about it but you guys have
heard when I got out of college and I
was starting stand up and I was
interning at the Daily Show which I got
an internship at the Daily Show I wasn't
even in college anymore it was a college
internship and I forged a letter on
stationery to say that I was still in
college just so I could get a free
internship and I commuted every day into
the city while I was living with my
folks or not every day I can I commuted
Mondays Wednesdays and Fridays to intern
at the Daily Show and then on Tuesdays
and Thursdays I was an assistant
salesman at electronics boutique which
most of you guys now know as Gamestop
and there was an older guy that worked
at the store and you could tell this guy
lived a rough life right like because if
you're just like the guy on the floor at
Gamestop you know you don't make much
money I don't remember what we were
making at the time maybe 10 bucks an
hour or something like that and you know
he was in his like probably mid to late
40s which seems sort of old to me at the
time right like I'm 20 out of college
and I remember one morning you're you
can picture a Gamestop you know they
have all those cardboard cutouts of the
videogame characters and all the big
posters of whatever the new Playstation
thing is or Xbox or whatever and we had
to put up some of the the new stuff and
I think we were putting up a pokeymon
thing like a big Pokemon cardboard
cutout and he's on the ladder and I'm
picking up the stuff and I'm handing it
to him and he leans down to grab
something and I heard something snap and
he screamed I mean the guy was writhing
in pain and he looked at me almost tears
in his eyes and this guy like I think I
think maybe he had been in jail actually
like he had lived he lived a rough life
this guy and he had this job because he
was trying to get his his daughter back
or something like that
and he looked at me and he goes Dave one
day your body will betray you and I
remember thinking like that is the
saddest most pathetic thing I've ever
heard in my life
and now at 44 with a torn ACL I tore I
tore my ACL four years ago playing
basketball
the last four years my my knee like if
I'm like you with the thing with the ACL
is you can't run laterally like this you
can run straight and you're fine right
so I do a lot of cardio I do the
elliptical machine you can run like that
but if you're playing sports where you
need to go side to side the ACL is
basically what keeps the knee in place
so for four years I've had a torn ACL
and I knew I didn't know I had a torn
ACL I knew I had a my knee was weak or
something like that anyway last August
we had my nieces and nephews here and I
was throwing them around the pool all
day long and I threw my nephew and I
felt something in my shoulder and I was
like oh and I bet a month later I was
like all right I gotta go to the doctor
I go get an MRI and I'm going into the
MRI machine if you haven't done an MRI
machine you're a lucky person it's not a
fun experience but you go into this
massive machine it feels very Total
Recall sci-fi dystopian it's it's really
kind of weird but they're putting me in
the machine and and I'm going headfirst
and as I'm going in the guys like well
do you have anything else wrong with you
as long as you're going into the machine
I was like you know well four years ago
I did bust my knee and I think
something's still not right he's like
alright well we'll take a look at that
too anyway the next day I get the call
with the results which I guess in the
old days used to take forever now they
do it literally in 24 hours I get the
call with the results and the doctors
like alright Dave I got good news and
bad news that's like all right he's like
your shoulders fine it's just a little
inflamed you know you don't have to do
anything some stretching and you'll be
all right
he's like the bad news is you don't have
an ACL so I tore my ACL to the point
that over the last four is it just
disappeared so so it's gone long story
short why the hell am I telling you this
your body will betray you young people
you young people watching YouTube enjoy
it while you got it so now I got to play
with a knee brace I'm not up to that
metal contraption level yeah that's the
sad thing when you see the old guy
stroll out onto the basketball court
he's got that metal contraption like
trap-jaw he's get out there and oh god
and he's it's all he's got left is the
big metal knee and it's it's a disaster
but anyway about 40 so I truly I think
look the stuff that I've been talking
about on this show is relevant right
like for some reason I don't know what
it is cosmically or whatever that I was
able to see
something five or six years ago that now
everyone sees and I was able to warn
about it for five or six years and I was
able to talk to all of the relevant
people who had been warning about it
thinking about it seeing it so it's very
validating like my life feels very
validated actually like I wake up
knowing that I'm doing something
important that I actually love to do I
very rarely have a second you know 20
I've been saying to to Michael who's our
new associate producer that my schedule
now that the booked or the six weeks of
that has calmed down my schedules a
little bit better cuz during that I had
I didn't have a minute during the day
like at the end of the day whenever we
wrapped up with my last interview with
nine o'clock sometimes eleven o'clock if
I was talking to somebody on the other
side of the world I could barely speak
at the end of the day like I was just
like my brain was just completely fried
and now my schedule is kind of loosened
up a little bit but it's still busy and
I wake up every day with something to do
something to talk about I try to you
know make the the craziness that we're
all in a little less painful I'm not
sure I always succeed at that you know I
try to make things not worse on Twitter
where everyone's making them worse one
of the things that I'm super psyched
about is that we've really built
something awesome with locals calm if
you guys haven't checked out I mean just
jump on Ruben report calm or download
the iOS app or the Android app you can
just search Ruben report we built out
some really cool tech that we're
building homes if you create anything
online like we will its your video it's
your audio it's your user data all of
that stuff we're trying to solve some of
the problems I don't make any money from
that but I put in a ton of time and I on
top of everything else like I went to
Silicon Valley this year and fundraise
and we did well and and it and it's
growing and that's awesome and by the
way you know this parlor thing is kind
of taking off too and I think that's
great Dan bond Gino is one of the guys
behind it and it's like there are many
ways to fight the big tech monster so I
want parler to do well I want locals to
do well I want more competition out
there so between between that the fact
that may was our biggest month ever on
YouTube across every freaking metric
that they that they count our audio
numbers have been great I feel like I'm
doing something important you know we're
getting big politicians reaching out to
us we have huge plans for the fall I've
got a couple other interesting offers
that would be separate from the Rubin
report that we're trying to figure out
what to do I don't know if you know this
there's an election coming in November
so like there's so many things that I
feel like what I do is right in the
center of and I guess so to really
answer your question like what do you
feel about 40s it's like I think the one
thing that I can tell you guys with
confidence is that if you do what you're
supposed to do whatever that is right
like and sometimes you don't even know
what it is and you just start doing it
and then time passes and you're like
holy cow I'm really doing what I'm
supposed to be doing well if you do what
you're supposed to do like time will
pass faster in a good sense but your
other things in your life will fall into
place my my relationships are good now
I've got an incredible team here that
that works for me
that I think feels validated in what
they do and feel like it's important
with what they're doing and I you know
because of this I I've been able to
build something that helps other people
live the lives that they want to live
that's pretty great
I'm just looking at the question again
about this stage of life oh how does it
compare to my younger years you know my
20 is a lot of my 20s were a mess I
talked about this in the book but I was
closeted for way too long and you know
you can be closeted about a lot of
things whatever it is I know a lot of
people are politically closeted right
now I'm sure a ton of you are
politically closeted there it's I
guarantee you there are people watching
this right now that you don't want to
share this video on your Facebook page
or wherever because you don't want you
know your friends or family knowing that
you you watch scary dave rubin and when
you're closeted about anything meaning
you hide something about yourself your
political views your sexuality whatever
the hell it is you're referring I don't
know whatever it is like when you hide
something about yourself well then the
people around you don't really know you
and you know there's really only room
for one in the closet and so in my 20s I
spent I was a messed up I was definitely
messed up and some of that residual
stuff I think even
even lasted into my 30 so my 40s I have
been much better I think I'm you know
and look 40s
yeah I'm complaining about the ACL on
the rest of it but like physically in
good shape I'm healthy you know I went
through I talked about the thing in the
book where I got developed this alopecia
areata thing and I lost like 40 or 45
percent of my hair I should actually
post one of the pictures from that it's
pretty miserable I haven't wanted to do
it but like this all does all my hair it
all came back you know I feel good about
life we're working on having kids we
have a new dog you know things are good
so I can't complain and I and I again I
think it all boils down to if if you
figure out what it is that you want to
do and then you just start doing it then
you do it again and again and again and
again it doesn't mean it's not gonna
suck a lot like we've had ups downs I've
had hit pieces you know New York Times
calling me alright you know all kinds of
crazy things but in many ways I now view
all of those things as the things that
got me here so it's like now when when
people write hit pieces about me or when
there's coordinated attacks you know
from reddit or any of this nonsense
it's like yeah you guys didn't kill me
and and in many ways you made me
stronger so I thank you for it so uh I
guess you live and learn I guess that's
the point all right thank you for the
question Janelle let's see what are some
of your all-time favorite bits or jokes
from comedians movies or TV shows well
I've talked about this a little bit that
the thing that really got me into comedy
I mean I remember 1983 I'm 7 years old
watching TV and I saw Bill Cosby himself
and it's it's I still think I know that
he's one of the biggest serial rapists
of all times nobody's perfect but I was
watching it and you may remember the
special he's got that great color sort
of reddish background he's in a brown
suit he's sitting on the stool and he
does the chocolate cake routine and the
dentist is the really famous one and a
bunch of others and I thought it was so
funny I couldn't believe that anything
could be that funny it was you know that
laugh when your your stomach the muscles
are you're in pain you're dying on the
Florida and I probably even understand
half of the things he was talking about
but just the way he spoke of the
chocolate cake dentists took the whole
thing like if the
Oh like I just thought it was the
funniest greatest thing ever and that
really is what got me into comedy in the
first place but a couple funny bits I
mean Naked Gun the original is is the
funniest movie of all time we watched it
again about two months ago it is the
funniest movie it's it's airplane humor
perfected you know that sort of
slapstick thing airplane got like 80% of
the way Naked Gun in my opinion just
perfected I remember seeing it in the
movie theater also dying in pain a guy
sitting in front of me in the movie
theater I was sitting in an aisle seat a
fat man fell out of his seat laughing so
that there's a clip that I I've been
posting every now and again now on
Twitter of a movie called see see no
evil hear no evil hear no evil see no
evil with Richard Pryor and Gene Wilder
and there's a great scene right at the
beginning of the movie where Richard
Pryor plays a black man and he's on the
subway with his sister plays a black man
he plays a blind man did I just say he
plays a black man now I'm gonna be
cancelled here we go he plays a blind
man and his sister says something and he
he gets up and he says I'm not white and
he does this whole thing thinking that
you know because he was blind he was a
white man it's actually totally
hilarious what are some of the other
great things I mean you know there's
another question about this I'll get to
further but like you know Curb Your
Enthusiasm and Seinfeld and some of that
kind of stuff
yeah you know it's funny because now you
know we're all trapped in our houses or
at least less but still to some degree
the two things that I've watched we
watched all of The Sopranos which I had
seen from beginning to end but David had
never seen it all and it's perfection
there's not a bad episode there's not
one throwaway episode it's absolute
perfection there's so much truth in
there there's a lot of interesting stuff
about social justice in there too so
Tony was not a fan of it by the way and
and living to a certain code and human
imperfections and all that stuff and
right now we are in I believe we're
about to start season 3 of Handmaid's
Tale which actually I've been wanting to
talk about a little bit
I won't I won't blow anything about
Handmaid's Tale but you know when it
came out about two or three years ago it
was sort of at the beginning of the
Trump presidency and act kept seeing all
these pieces online and people on
Twitter saying this is Trump's America
we're gonna slave in slave women and
dinner to do and no one's gonna be
talking anymore in censorship and all
this stuff and it's like now I'm
watching it and it's like no this is
literally what the progressives on the
left and the Marxists and these lunatic
BLM anti-shah this is what they're
bringing this silence and political
correctness and and violence and all of
this stuff this is what they are
assuring in so the fact that people
thought it was it was Trump and the
scary conservatives now we're gonna have
women in Chains again and all this stuff
it's like you guys got this whole
freaking thing backwards so if you
haven't seen the Handmaid's Tale and you
want to watch a piece of fiction that is
actually relevant to what's going on but
not in the way that the mainstream media
or that just the general Twitterati will
tell you
check out the Handmaid's Tale it's not
very funny though that is one of the
things a lot of rape a lot of rape okay
Robert says given all the recent chaos
and bad polls and recognizing that this
is 2020 and the months to November could
see things radically shift 15 times how
do you think the election is gonna go
well I think the middle part of your
question is the key part no one wants to
be in the prediction game ever it
usually does not work out well I've had
a pretty freakin good track record on
predictions especially on this sort of
the big level the high level stuff but
yes not only can anything happen but
like weirder particularly anything can
happen and the media can pretend
anything happen moment so it's not just
what reality is it's what the media will
let us see with reality so like with
corona right now I think one of the
interesting things is it does sound like
there is starting to be some sort of a
bump which basically everybody said by
the way you know didn't matter where you
were left right whatever else the people
that were calling for opening up we're
not denying that that could cause a bump
they were saying well we just can't stay
lockdown forever so we have to try it
and see what happens and the people that
wanted us lockdown forever were saying
oh there's gonna be a bump either way so
nobody has like a perfect crystal ball
relative to what's gonna happen I think
part of the exhaustion of the whole
thing is nobody knows who to trust right
we're supposed to wear masks we
shouldn't wear masks Falchi says this
the w-h-o says this you know originally
we were supposed to flatten the curb
which we did everywhere now we're
continuing lockdowns now watch
in state wants you in a mask all the
time my my brother-in-law just left
Washington State wisely with his
girlfriend you know so I think we have a
we have an issue related to just the
trust level like there's the reality
level of whatever is real related to
Corona whatever is real related to
protests and violence and all that stuff
and then there's the media layer that
that's the filter that then gets to us
so it's like depending on if you watch
MSNBC or Fox or YouTube or whatever like
your filter is gonna be so different
than somebody else's that it's almost
like we're living in in multiple
realities right like so if you watch my
show let's say you watch my show you
listen to some Shapiro you watch a Rogen
every now and again you know some of
some of the online stuff and then pick
take that type of person now it doesn't
mean we're all right about everything
but take that type of person you listen
to some Jordan Peterson lectures
whatever that is now imagine if you're
just somebody that listens to whatever
lefty YouTube is or MSNBC or whatever
like your reality is so different that
it's like you're gonna think you're
getting the same information but you're
not and I think that I'm more concerned
about that than the specifics of the
virus like we've done a pretty good job
right no hospital was overrun as far as
I know that isn't it doesn't mean that
some of them were in strained I have a
friend who's a doctor that was at a
pretty strained Hospital but but none of
them were overrun we don't have millions
and millions of young sick people older
people got sick and older people died
and by the way Andrew Cuomo in New York
you know sent a lot of older sick people
back into nursing homes and tons of them
died and then he's on that clown shows
CNN yesterday or the day before with his
brother and they pretend like it's like
it's such it's like a bad comedy skit
with the two of them and they're spray
tans are just seeing both of them but
they're talking about what a great job
Andrew Cuomo did and how much better
than Florida and it's my numbers are not
gonna be right here so maybe my guys
could check it but it's something like
33,000 people have died in New York and
3,000 of died in Florida can someone
check those numbers for me and
it's like and I get the populations or
different population centers are
different all that stuff but like oh you
did such a great job and being
interviewed by his brother it's all just
it's all just kind of gross so I think
in terms of predictions it's like yeah
could we have a sudden spike in
September and not or not even a spike
but a media concocted spike and you know
what's gonna happen with with mail and
voting I mean this whole mail and voting
thing is so insane so basically every
Democrat is suddenly forward and it's
like between the riots the protests the
pandemic the general unease about
everything and suddenly we're also going
to check we're also gonna change how we
do our voting like everyone know is that
the only reason the Democrats want is
because they're gonna figure out how to
fix it that way and as long as I'm going
down that road you know this idea of
mostly virtual convention that the
Democrats are gonna have that's partly
corona related but it's also because
they want to hide Biden they can't have
him out there the guy obviously has
cognitive decline we all know it but
it's there's something even worse than
that
which is they don't want a convention
because their base which is these
Marxists and lunatics and anti fat
people and all that they're gonna burn
down the freakin convention they were
trying to burn it down a couple years
ago you didn't see much about that on
mainstream media because they didn't
want to show you that it could be that
side that's violent right it's only the
scary white supremacist Trump supporters
that nobody can find so man so how do
you predict all this stuff like I don't
even I've been saying for a while I
still am not convinced Biden is gonna be
the nominee I mean I don't think he's I
don't even if he is the person that is
going to run against Trump for sure I
mean get the Democratic nomination and
go ahead I don't think he's really their
nominee like it's it's the party leaders
at the DNC who are just pushing out this
old man that they can control and
they're just hoping that he can speak
long enough to make it through but
they've been hiding him out because they
know that's a disaster but in effect you
I think you could make an argument that
the Marxists and the Bernie progressives
and just that awful crew of people I
think my guys might be giving me some
numbers here guys can you get me the
numbers on Florida in New York before I
move too far
the Florida and New York corona death
rates I think in many ways you
could argue that the Bernie crew did
actually win because all of the riots
and the protests and all that that's
what they wanted right like that is what
they wanted the Bernie people have been
saying this on Twitter all the time
Lefty's this is what they want like they
didn't they didn't they didn't want to
win honestly they wanted to win however
they could win and they will gladly burn
down the system let's not forget that
Peabody judge who has no opinions about
anything he's the most but knowing
nothing he was saying in that last
debate you can vote for Bernie but he
wants to burn the system down well now
they're doing it so that so all of these
rioters and all that they're just doing
the Democrats dirty work that doesn't
mean that every Democrat is bad it
doesn't mean that every lefty is bad but
they have nobody nobody that can stand
up to this thing the only guy who maybe
could have done it would have been Obama
that Obama could have just come out and
been like no way I believe in law and
order and ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
which by the way would have been
protecting his legacy because in many
ways when they're telling you how racist
and awful and imperial and blah blah
blah that America is it's like oh well
he was president for eight years so the
whole thing Biden's running now on this
idea that America is so evil well
America didn't just become evil in the
three years of Trump right actually if
you if you remove the last few months of
riots and Korona try to think back about
three years before everything was
actually pretty good now the media was
telling you that rut we were Russia and
Ukraine and the making of things all the
time that all always turned out to be
wrong World War three we killed
Soleimani
net net neutrality we're all gonna die
but really if the if you're voting for
Biden because you think America is evil
it's like that's a serious frickin
condemnation of Obama so you're really
condemning a Biden this is very little
to do with Trump so it's a really I
think there and it's just the whole
thing's a disaster they're gonna pick
some progressive maybe Elizabeth Warren
who knows well I mean I guess they have
to go a minority woman because the whole
thing is so stupid so they'll pick
somebody and it's like that's probably
who the president is if it's not the
party leaders so in terms of predictions
of the whole damn thing I mean I still
think that if if you just look back at
2016 like is there any one that's that
voted for Trump that's suddenly going to
be like I've decided to vote for the
Oh lefties I was wrong about his hair
and his color of his skin and the tweets
I'm voting for the radical lefties like
I don't think there's anybody are there
people who are so frustrated with what
the left has become that they're not
gonna do it publicly but they are gonna
vote for Trump because he wants to keep
the wheels on capitalism and America and
all that I do think plenty of those
people exist I'm meeting them on the
streets in a ballet believe it or not so
my guess is Trump wins but you know now
it's all it's of course about voter
turnout this mail-in ballot stuff how
Corona is gonna affect all this and it's
like by the way you know now there's all
these think pieces in the usual Politico
Hill nonsense about will Trump leave if
he loses and it's like you guys didn't
accept the results of the election last
time you have spent every second trying
to topple this guy with fake
investigations and a gajillion other
thing so you know you get it you guys
get it all right I got some updated
numbers on on COBIT so in Florida there
were a hundred fourteen thousand cases
and three thousand three hundred deaths
in New York there were three hundred
ninety thousand cases so that's over
three times as more three times more
cases and there were twenty four
thousand eight hundred deaths that's
about five that's about what seven times
the amount of deaths and yet you've got
Chris Cuomo telling Andrew Cuomo what an
amazing job he's done now I'm not a
perfectly equated the the populations
and where they're all centralized and
all of that stuff but it's just it's
just silly propaganda I mean watching
CNN is basically watching the WWE
they're just poorly written skits that's
it okay Lauren says if if is there
someone you haven't interviewed that you
really wish you could to make happen why
I've answered this one a couple times so
my usual answer is Bill Maher because I
think he's basically sort of the last
sort of mainstream sane lefty voice you
know good on free speech he has a you
know a touch of Trump derangement
syndrome
more than a touch but you know I think
he's he's a good old-fashioned liberal
now obviously I've become more right
than he is let's say more libertarian
than he is although I think in essence
he really is
the libertarian who wants to smoke pot
and you know bang chicks and do do
whatever it is that he does and I think
that's great that's his right to do it I
would love to have that conversation
with him about what has happened for the
left what has happened to the last
liberals who were all gone you know one
of the interesting things is I was
supposed to be on Real Time with Bill
Maher I think on May 28th so almost a
month ago today actually and and they
canceled me and I knew when we got
booked I was supposed to be on for the
book and we got booked I was like
something is gonna happen and it just
ain't gonna happen because I I wanted to
do it my whole life when I started doing
stand-up in 98 a long time ago god
that's a lot I wanted to be on
politically incorrect which was Bill
Maher's ABC show that eventually became
real time so I've wanted to I've chatted
with him privately two or three times
very very small conversations actually I
will tell you this I don't think I've
ever said this publicly before but it's
my birthday I'm opening up to you
there's people I I met Bill Maher at a
party once about five years ago and I
introduced myself Ruben I'm a comic I
show bah-bah-bah and I think he had
heard about me from from a few of our
mutual friends and I said bill you gotta
watch out for the left there they're the
ones that are gonna come for you and he
goes in perfect sort of like smug Bill
Maher Sally's like nah I got the left I
don't have to worry about that
and whatever the conversation went on
for another minute and that's it and
it's like who do you guys think is gonna
take out Bill Maher when they come to
take out Bill Maher who's gonna do it is
it gonna be the Conservatives the Trump
supporters the people on the right who
take out Bill Maher no because actually
those are the ones that defend Bill
Maher all the time every time Bill Maher
is a clip Bove iral it's a bunch of
conservatives gonna you know I disagree
with Bill on a lot but he's getting it
right on this who's always trying to
cancel Bill Maher it's the freakin crazy
bananas lefties so I think I was ahead
of seeing the thing that we now all see
and I would love to talk to him about
that but since I always answer that
question with Bill Maher who would I
love to talk to you know who I would
love to talk to who I do text with every
now and again is my favorite basketball
player of all time who oh I was gonna
say my basketball here is signed by him
but that's that's in the house Clyde
Drexler he was a player on the blazer
in late 80s Early 90s eventually won a
championship with the Rockets and you
know they just did this last dance thing
on ESPN about Michael Jordan and Jordan
and Clyde Clyde was always sort of
number two to Jordan for those years and
they played the same position and Jordan
just annihilated everybody right he
annihilated magic the first year and he
mad at Clyde the second year and Barkley
the third championship and Peyton for
the fourth and Malone and Stockton for
the fifth and six he just took out
everybody but Clyde was right there
playing in the same position was never
quite as good as Jordan nobody is right
but Jordan was pretty disrespectful to
him in the in the last dance thing and I
would love to talk to - Clyde about that
I know it's like a little offshoot of
what I normally do around here but I
think that would be interesting let's
see we did the thoughts of life a couple
things about the election so I there's a
lot about the election what's your
favorite album if not some of your
favorites so I'll give you a couple
things then I'll I'll tell you a
specific album
so generally lately so because I worked
from home for years but now like we're
all working from home I find if you're
working from home and you're struggling
or just to keep like the energy up or
whatever it is like you're missing human
interaction or whatever
I found a channel on Spotify by a band
called Schwarzenegger I have no idea who
these guys are
Schwarzenegger and it's sort of all like
ambient chill music and they've got
about ten albums on there and you can
pick a whole bunch of different ones I
like the departure sessions in the
morning I usually just click play on
that get it going throughout the whole
house it's a nice way to start the day
and then they have a couple I think
they're called Diamond albums there's
like a Ruby Diamond an emerald diamond
and a Blue Diamond the Ruby Diamond the
red one is is just great for sort of
afternoon if you just want some
afternoon ambience oh I really like
chill and ambient stuff during the day I
don't want to hear words in my music
during the day because I'm talking all
the time I'm listening to people talk
all the time I find it hard to work and
hear other people talking or singing so
that I've been really big on that lately
I also
found somebody found this band this
synth wave band I mentioned doing
stand-up once that I've really been into
synth wave lately and somebody found
this band the midnight who I freaking
absolutely love and they have they do
have words in their songs but there's
instrumental versions of a bunch of
their stuff they're called the midnight
and but really if I'm if I'm listening
to like if it's at night and we're
cooking we're eating we have friends
over like I'm old school
I love Frankie Valli in the four seasons
the last two concerts that I've been to
were Frankie Valli at at 85 years old I
just love it listen you could so my
favorite album right now like if I was
playing one album tonight you could
there's a Frankie Valli and the Four
Seasons Greatest Hits live in Jersey
where they go back home to Jersey and
they do a couple medleys where they
don't Phil do the full songs but they
just do them like in succession with
each other and it's just great and it's
like man Frankie Valli that voice he was
also a new Prados for a couple episodes
which I had completely forgot about but
I we do a lot of Sinatra a lot of Dean
Martin I love the old the old crooners
and then like for for dinner parties
again I don't like if you're talking I
don't like a lot of talking in the music
so if we're sitting down with people for
dinner I do like Count Basie or Duke
Ellington that kind of stuff I am old
school what can I tell you
44 years old a wish a lesson and a
resolution for this year Wow that's a
good one a wish well my wish for sure is
that we can start resetting this thing
and I do sense that underneath the
craziness right now there are a lot of
you guys that are getting a little bit
braver you're starting to speak up a
little bit more you realize that your
silence only gives room to the bad
actors and the bad ideas and so my wish
is that we get a little braver and we
start pushing back on this nonsense
that's the wish a lesson although I
guess a lesson that I've learned well I
guess this is sort of what I said before
but just do something just do something
whatever it is you think you're supposed
to do start doing it don't be afraid if
you want to try stand up try that if you
want to learn how to play the drum
try it if you want to learn how to code
learn to code whatever you want to do
just get out there and start doing it
that is the Oh it's in many ways it's
like the only lesson in life just go and
do something because if you do it if you
do it any do it and you do it and you
fail that will be better than not having
done it right it's better to have loved
and lost than never loved at all do it
do it and if you until you this like
there were many times in my career where
I was like I don't know how much longer
I can do this it's not working out the
way I wanted this didn't happen or that
didn't happen or my friend got this gig
and I didn't get that or all those
things but if you just keep doing it and
then every time you get to that
precipice that moment that cliff where
you're like I don't know if I can take
it anymore if you just keep going the
cliff keeps moving the cliff keeps
moving so there are cliffs in my future
for sure and hopefully I can just keep
playing through them you know that
that's it and a resolution I guess a
resolution for me will be that I will be
able that I'll be able to uphold the the
ideals that I talk about here you know
in many ways it's a lot easier to do to
be respectful and decent and open and
honest and all that stuff it's a lot
easier to do when I'm interviewing
somebody whether it's by Skype or if
somebody's in here versus the simplicity
of social media the simplicity of
Twitter where you go after people and
yeah you know yeah firebombs somebody on
Twitter and you have all of that stuff
and I try not to do it too much and then
and then sometimes I do some loser
person a daily beast person went after
me yesterday because I said I agree with
Tucker Carlson on his monologue from
yesterday which was fantastic so I
tweeted something back and I was trying
to be like kind of funny I was like well
I totally agree with Tucker and so does
Clyde and I took a picture of Clyde and
as you guys probably know from some of
the videos and pictures you've seen of
Clyde Clyde is a huge scar on his head
right here and there's some scar tissue
behind that and we don't know exactly
what it's from because that he was found
on the streets abandoned and it was he
was obviously either the vet
the first vet said he thought it was
like a pretty severe like intentional
cigarette burn but it could be much
worse I mean it could have been that he
was actually stabbed like sees a lot of
scar tissue here anyway I posed this
picture and all these tolerant lefties
are telling me that I abused my dog and
what's wrong with him and all this [ __ ]
and then I did retweet a couple of them
saying oh well you know actually he was
abandoned and due to be killed that day
he was gonna be put down at the shelter
and we adopted him and he's living a
pretty good life right now like what's
wrong with you that that sort of thing I
did it to a couple people and it's like
yeah it's it's good to tell the story
about him and whatever and fight back
when people are just saying awful things
as if I abuse my dog or whatever but
maybe just a resolution would be just to
try to let some of that stuff just go
instead of diving into it too much but
that's one of those things where we all
have these moments where there are
moments in life where you can let a lot
of stuff just roll off your back and
then there's other moments where you
where you want to fight back more so
there you go let's say let's see Dave
which of the following is most likely
for you and your husband one we're
staying in California two we're moving
to Texas three we're moving to Florida
all right all right people we have a sip
of coffee before I answer we've done a
lot of thinking about this we've done a
lot a lot a lot a lot of thinking about
this I've been talking about it I've
been tweeting about it I've got a 400
billion people roughly in Texas that are
welcoming me and want to show me around
and help me get guns and build the fort
the whole thing I've always loved
Florida my folks have a have a little
place in Florida that I've always loved
to go to the summers can be pretty
brutal but you can you can always get
out of there for the summers financially
it would make way more sense to be in
Texas with no state income tax or
Florida with no state income tax than
California with our thirteen percent on
top of whatever LA's is and I've we've
been talking about it for two months now
and trying to figure out what we're
gonna do I think that the decision is
that we're gonna fight it out here
at least for a couple years I don't want
to give up on California I mean that
sort of at the personal level of I'm not
a quitter and I meet too many people I'm
meeting people on the streets right now
I'm telling you I'm meeting people on my
street who are coming up to me going
Dave I've been a lefty my whole life
this place is out of control now maybe
we have to do something I'm getting a
lot of messages from people that want to
figure out how to fix it here you know
California was not always a progressive
dystopia Ronald Reagan was the Governor
of California okay he was he was more
lefty at the time but like the point is
that there is a chance that some of this
stuff could be reset Arnold
Schwarzenegger was a Republican governor
governor of California not not too long
ago so I think there is a chance so I
want to stay and fight for a couple of
years I really do I don't want to flee I
also think that beyond me it's like the
message that I would be sending to
people you know I talked about the foot
vote all the time if you don't like
what's happening in your state you got
to go to another state but you know if
all of the good people leave California
go to Texas well first off we know what
happens these blue people go to red
states and then they turn them blue so
if I was you Texas I'd be building a
wall and not letting any Californians in
or at least make them sign something I'm
pretty sure that would be a good idea
but putting that aside for a second I
you know what will America be if if we
really really split into just red states
first just blue states because all the
populations transfer so that it's just
this and just that it's like we will not
have anything close to national cohesion
so if you think that that we're
struggling right now when it comes to
national cohesion it could get much much
much much worse
I think you always need a healthy
opposition and I probably will never be
really in the majority here but I do
want to fight it out for a little bit
longer I know that's going to disappoint
my people in Texas but that is it
favorite 90s show also a request for a
birthday dance party perhaps with your
pup I don't know if the dance party is
gonna happen favorite 90s show
I mean Seinfeld debuted in 89 I think
end of 89 and it lasted till 98 it's the
best sitcom ever
I mean I don't think there's anything
close there's as I said before about the
Sopranos there's virtually no throwaway
episode in Seinfeld it's just perfect
you know the clip I posted a clip this
last week or two weeks ago about The
Blackout meme and that everyone was
being forced into the blackout mean
which was exactly who looked where the
ribbon is from the aides march in in
Seinfeld when Kramer goes to the March
so he's doing the right thing but then
he just doesn't want to wear the ribbon
and then what happens the tolerant
people at the aids March beat the crap
out of him that's very much what
happened with our blackout meme it
wasn't just that you didn't if you
didn't post it you were okay if you
didn't post it we were gonna destroy you
too
there's just so many it really is comedy
perfection you know I love curb to
that's obviously not 90s and and of
course I always have to give a shout-out
to my Golden Girls although that I
consider that more of a 80s show because
it debuted in 85 went off the air in May
of 92 I remember watching it and I had
tears in my eyes
Chris says if you could pick one Star
Wars film which would it be Chris I'm
gonna go controversial on yeah I think
legally I have to answer one Star Wars
question during all of these live
streams I'm gonna say Revenge of the
Sith the the prequels you guys all know
my feelings on this so I won't I won't
belabor the point but I have been saying
for years the prequels are gonna be
looked back at better and better and
better as time goes on I think a lot of
people are waking up to it SIF is a
pretty perfect movie - a little bit of
stiff acting but seeing the culmination
of what Palpatine's plan was watching
Anakin turn to the dark side
understanding what order 66 was
Palpatine I mean this idea that you
create a war and then shut down one of
the sides as you've accumulated power
it's such a great political story that
nobody really talks about we only talk
about Star Wars related to the force so
I'm gonna say Revenge of the Sith I'll
also say one other quick thing on Star
Wars you know the last three were pretty
pretty terrible force awakens I like the
middle one was so bad that the that rise
of Skywalker then just had to clean it
up and JJ did whatever whatever he could
do oh by the way speaking to JJ Hiram's
did you see his company whatever his
production company is they just released
this like handbook on how to fight white
supremacy and include
and have diversity and inclusion in the
in the workplace and it's the worst
social justice BS nonsense it's like jjy
it's apparently you're hiring an awful
lot of racist people I don't need a
diversity and inclusion workforce for my
people I don't hire racist people
everybody's fine here you know so but
anyway putting that aside but you know I
think one of the marks of a good movie
is if you watch it the more you watch it
the more you can learn something in it
so for example we did a Reuben Report
movie day movie afternoon we did the
movie contact with Jodie Foster it's a
book the book originally was written by
Carl Sagan and I've seen it many times
and usually I find when I watch that
movie there's a little something I can
learn more each time about it and that's
what a good movie does if you watch The
Godfather
you can watch you 20 times you will
learn a little bit more a little more
intricacies about the characters the
looks everything will make it richer and
richer and richer the more you watch the
last three Star Wars the worse they get
because force awakens which on its own
was good well then it gets ruined by all
of the stuff in the last Jedi and then
JJ's just cleaning it up but one of the
things that he did that was terrible I
think in and Raisa Skywalker was every
time you're about to have an emotional
moment they take it away from you so
when when rey crashes the plant of the
space cruiser with Force Lightning well
you think Chewbacca is dead there's a
that's a real moment nobody wants
Chewbacca to be dead that is a sad
moment and it feels like an ending of
Star Wars Chewbacca is gonna die
five minutes later Oh Chewbacca happened
to be in another cruiser that we didn't
see c-3po his memory is wiped out you
think oh my god this is the end of c-3po
he's a robot if he doesn't have memory
that's it he's done then his memory
starts coming back so every time there's
an emotional moment they take away the
emotion five minutes later but what that
does is when you now see the movie the
second time you you what's supposed to
be emotional is reverse emotional
there's no emotion to it because you're
like oh that thing that I'm watching
happened it doesn't happen so I think
they just mucked up the whole thing I
have no idea how they get out of it
however I did watch the last season of
Clone Wars and it was freaking
spectacular and maybe that's just what
the future of Star Wars has to be it has
to be more graphic animation and going
deep into that
part of the universe but what they did
with Darth Maul and with ahsoka it was
spectacular okay um let's see happy
birthday Dave keep doing what you're
doing love your show will you go on Joe
Rogan's podcast and will you have
libertarian presidential VP candidate on
your show before the election will I go
on Rogen's podcast I asked him and our
PR people asked him about a bajillion
times to go on for my book we did not
get a response as far as I know so I
don't know what happened there it's a
little weird for me to say that publicly
I don't know what happened and will I oh
yeah Joe Jorgenson who's the Libertarian
candidate we've reached out to her
people a zillion times and in very
libertarian fashion we're not getting a
great response I don't know what's
happened in there but yes Joe you're
watching this I'd love to have you on
let's talk about libertarianism Zippity
dippity all right there's a lot of stuff
here um what is a favorite non political
memory of yours what so though so what's
a favorite memory favorite memory
favorite memory favorite memory trying
to think of like a good childhood like
what's a great childhood memory um uh I
got I got a good one I remember going to
Disney is a Disney World or Disneyland
whichever ones in Miami in Orlando in
Florida we went when I was about 12
years old my brother was about nine my
sister was probably like four and they
did the you know they do the the big
shows where they grab people out of the
audience and they grabbed me and my
brother and my sister and we were with
some family friends they grabbed
basically the whole crew of kids and
they dressed us up and we were
Gilligan's Island and you know you're in
front of like 500 people and I was
Gilligan and we're on a boat and you
know they're yelling at you what to do
and people are laughing at you and
they've got you know water raining down
on you because the boats gonna crash and
they got fake lightning and I'm wearing
the hat and I'm Gilligan with the shirt
and the whole thing and I never really
thought about it till just now but I
guess maybe that was one of the first
times I realized I liked laughter I like
when people laugh because I remember I
was kind of hamming it up in the boat
and it was just like I just love
everything about not only Disney World
and Epcot and Universal Studios like
seeing the how it's all made and the
sound effects and like all the cool
technical stuff that goes goes behind
that I always liked it now right now I
live very close to Universal which every
time people visit in the old days when
you used to be able to leave your house
I would take people people would visit
me and then I would take them out say to
the beach or to Universal Studios or
even to Ikea
and we would go out and do things we
don't do that as well often these days
but I love I love going there I love all
that stuff I'm not a huge ride guy I get
I get kind of motion sickness on the on
the hardcore roller coaster so I I hate
roller coasters but I will plow through
for the other stuff so I you know at
Universal they've got an awesome
transformers ride as bad as the
Transformers movies are the ride it's so
cool and we had I had a fan that got us
down to Star Wars the new Star Wars at
Disney here for an advanced thing and
although it actually wasn't great like I
just love everything behind it like I
just love that they build these things
and all of that good stuff let's see um
to the man who changed my life happy
birthday no not one moment has impacted
my life more than when I came across
your interview with DeFranco Phil
DeFranco I was hooked from there my red
pill is all do to you and I'm eternally
thankful have a wonderful day filled
with nothing but love and positivity
stay off Twitter it'll help I promise
you I will birthday question what's your
favorite cake flavor in case someone
wants to make you a cake and you spell
flavor Fla B oh you are so I know you're
British
very fancy uh what's my favorite cake
flavor well I could tell you this I'm
going out with friends tonight and I
know if that if I'm involved in the in
the choosing of the dessert although
maybe they'll beat me to the punch
I always go for like it you give me like
a serious Chocolate Lava gooey chocolaty
mess I am very very happy but that being
said cake is not my favorite dessert ice
cream I love ice cream I could eat ice
cream every day
I don't eat ice cream every day but I
absolutely could you give me a good life
serious mint chocolate-chip cookie dough
cookies and cream really I love ice
cream and I wish I was eating ice cream
right now
Steven happy birthday Dave thank you for
being a positive influence in the lives
of so many people my question is are you
and David planning more interviews
together so some of you guys may have
seen this we did a David interviewed me
for an hour which we posted as a as an
exclusive for people that pre-ordered
don't burn this book but we did post one
like 12 minute clip of it on the channel
which you guys can find and it was what
we talked about in that clip was meeting
Trump when we met Trump at mar-a-lago
and he realized we were gay he stood up
and he shook our hands and he was like I
don't give a [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ]
and then David and Melania hung out for
a little bit and then I I had Trump I
was having dinner with Trump jr. and he
got pulled away and then I had a few
minutes just with Trump and he was just
totally nice and friendly and I told
this before but I I said him it's an
honor to meet you mr. president and he
looked at me like yeah you could call me
Don like he couldn't have cared less but
there's a full interview where we talk
about how we met and what it's been like
and actually I should mention this today
is my birthday June 26 David and I
actually met on my birthday today 10
years ago it was at the gay pride parade
in fact and I actually remembered the
second he walked into the room so it is
a June 26 is a good one
for me Charlie wants to know how will
Clyde join in the celebrations today
well first off Clyde is freaking out
right now because we have my staff is
here today so we've got a bunch of
people in the house and we usually now
because we're doing stuff still remote
mostly we don't have a lot of people in
the house so the fact things people in
house when right before we started the
livestream David looked at me he said
look at Clyde's eyes his eyes are
dilated like he just did a whole bunch
of mushrooms like he is so overly
stimulated right now but he has been
getting trained for the last month we've
had a dog trainer here and he the guy
did an amazing job because Clyde was
getting a little nutty a lot of barking
chewing on literally everything like he
you know he ate the first copy of don't
burn this book I mean the guy was just
plowing through everything every kind of
food he pizza boxes whatever he could
find but the training actually worked it
was
and now he's like totally cool he's got
a lot of energy you know he's won he's
got a lot of energy did cartoons and
movies from your youth play any role in
the development of your personal
principles I love that question all
right cartoons for my youth I mean the
big two would be would be transformers
and GI Joe I suppose they probably did
well if GI Joe now I know and knowing is
half the battle right that was the PSA
that they did after the thing and it's
like yeah you know about something then
that is head actually that's probably
bout 80% of the battle I guess that
doesn't sound it's clean but I loved GI
Joe I loved transformers had all the you
know all the toys I know all the toys I
had I had a lot of the toys I still got
Soundwave I posted a picture Soundwave
the other day I've got my old school
sound wave with ravage in there ravage
was the Panther that was in sound way
its chest
I've got an old Storm Shadow which was
one of the hardest GI Joe characters to
find got Millett storm travel his crotch
is blown out that happened with a lot of
GI Joes and sometimes the rubberband
would get whatever buddies he has he has
no nuts basically but I've got Storm
Shadow and I've got I've got Soundwave
and I've got a Boba Fett an original
Boba Fett over there but did those
things shape me in any way um I don't
know but I will tell you this I remember
seeing the Transformers movie and one of
my guys do a check what year did the
original Transformers movie come out the
cartoon movie I'm guessing it was
probably around 88 something like that
no no maybe 86 can we get a check on
that guys the original transformers
cartoon movie and I went to see it with
my my grandma took me and she took me
and my brother and we go and I'm
probably 11 or so when we get the year
on that and so we go we watch it and if
you remember this movie it is nothing
like the Michael Bay transformer movies
first up it's a cartoon the soundtrack
is amazing it is like a tease hardcore
rock it's so cool the animation they
really upped it and it's all hand
animation which is awesome but in the
movie Optimus Prime dies right at the
beginning of the movie and I remember
crying in
and I remember looking at my brother and
crying and he's crying and we're crying
Optimus Prime I remember we got out and
I was still crying at the end because
they referenced something about Optimus
at the end and I remember whatever was
11 years I remember I thinking I should
not be seen crying I didn't want my
grandma to see me crying I didn't well
if there were other kids everybody
walked out 1986 I was right so I was 10
years old walked out of there crying
that is not really relevant to what I
learned about the movie what did I learn
from it from the lessons well you got to
fight for what you believe in
that's what Optimus Prime did that's
what Duke and the GI Joe people did they
fought for what they thought was right
versus Megatron and Cobra Commander
because what were Megatron and Cobra
Commander oh he's doing they always
wanted all the power and what did they
decide to do if they couldn't get the
power almost every episode of GI Joe
ended like this Cobra Commander being
like I can't have it nobody can and
that's basically what the modern left is
if it's not exactly how they want it
they're gonna burn down the whole thing
and that's what Cobra Commander would do
they be they be trying to do something
with their weather machine or their
cloning system or some crazy idea that
they had much like the bananas ideas of
Marxists and if they couldn't get it
exactly as they wanted they burned down
the whole system so I guess I did learn
a little something from Optimus Prime
and and Duke and the Joe's um let's see
I'm trying to avoid some of the purely
political ones out here's just a fun
quick one who's your favorite Seinfeld
character excluding Jerry
well Jerry is definitely not my favorite
character I mean I think I go in phases
with all four of them where I'm like man
I just loved this one right now Jerry or
Kramer or George or Elaine but Frank
Costanza who actually just passed away
Jerry Stiller passed away about a month
or two ago he was I think in his late
90s he's Ben Stiller's father of course
and his wife and Mira they were a comedy
duo in the 50s and 60s and I bumped into
Jerry a couple times we used to live a
block or two away on the Upper West I
would see him on the street we would
talk about comedy he was so nice and
friendly and loving and just a good good
good good man but every he stole every
freaking scene he was in inside every
single scene
how can alternative Platteville
like yours capture the attention of
those persuadable people in the middle
it's a great question because I think
what we're seeing right now is so I'll
talk about locals in a sec but you know
parlor is gaining some traction right
now and it's really interesting because
you know unlike gap which gab took a lot
of the trolls and all that stuff and I'm
not knocking gab in any way and I think
in many ways what they've built
technologically is great but what
happened was he was maybe a little early
in the game and then and then the media
just goes on it to destroy it and then
people are afraid of getting on there so
the gap things not gonna work parlor now
seems to be getting some mainstream
people generally people that that lean
right I was leaning left there but that
lean this way but they're getting some
real people I just saw Rick Bernal just
got on there it's funded or at least
partly by Dan bonds you know I just got
the at Rubin report handle on there
there was someone impersonating me and I
had thousands of followers so they just
gave me that that handle I haven't
posted anything there yet
but seeing that something is gaining
steam whether it's gonna ultimately work
whether the idea of replacing Twitter is
exactly what the right answer is whether
having parallel things is good or bad or
whether this actually just siphons us
off and gets us more in our echo chamber
I don't know the answer to any of that
nobody knows the answer to any of that
but I think having some competitive
things out there is good and showing
people modeling for people that we can
build things on our own that won't be
reliant on big tech overlords these are
all good things
I actually just message Bonjean oh this
morning because we've built something
that is seriously awesome with locals
and it is hugely exploding right now
because people are realizing you can't
be reliant on big tech so while parler
is basically a twitter clone and that's
great completely great what we're doing
with locals is we're giving you tools to
build an online community for yourself
so if you want a place where it's you
are owning the video you're owning the
audio you are owning the pictures the
content the user data
the locals app if you go just search
locals calm in the iOS store or an
Android play and you can download the
app for free you can jump between
communities you can send push
notifications to your to your audience
it's we built something that's real and
you can monetize it through subscription
I mean we built something that's really
slick but I just emailed bond you know
cuz I'm like there there might be some
ways we could do some touch points
here and work together because there's
many ways to skin a cat I love
competition I don't even think we're
competition I think
let's keep hitting this thing let's you
know every think of every battle every
war every whatever it's like you got
foot soldiers you got guys in
helicopters you got the the bombers you
got the whole thing that's how you
attack something so I love the fact that
people are getting brave right now but I
think we've built something so cool with
locals we've we've raised a nice chunk
of change as I told you guys before I
don't take a dime actually starting in
July I'll be totally honest with you I
am gonna take a tiny bit of money
because I do in effect a lot of my time
is working for locals but the entire
year and a half we've built this thing I
haven't taken a dime I've just put a lot
of time in obviously I own a nice
percentage of it so if something amazing
happens that'll be great but that really
isn't why I did it like I wanted to
build something for me that was gonna
protect my stuff and that's exactly what
we did so so Rueben report.com is the
first project of locals and now Scott
Adams is on there and Bridget fed Izzy
and you're on Brook and Karlin borisenko
and a whole bunch of people and it's
like anyone that's on there if you're
watching this one of my trolls one of my
troll haters on YouTube I know you guys
watch all my videos and you wait for me
to say something that you can take out
of context if you're watching this and
you absolutely hate me but you're a
content creator of any kind you can sign
up at locals comm you can use our set of
tools to build a digital home and then
you can hate on Dave Rubin all day long
in your locals because I'm not building
something now for me we built it using
to solve my needs first and now I think
we can give it to everybody else to
truly be free from big tech so it's not
a replacement of Twitter or YouTube or
any of those things but if you look
nothing stopping YouTube from kicking me
off tomorrow just a fact right like it's
just reality I don't like that reality
it just is all of our videos are on
locals we have a sick awesome really
clean video player that I absolutely
love there's no ads on there there's ad
free podcast and all that stuff you can
buy tickets to things and there's just a
great community and there's no trolls
because you got to pay a couple bucks to
get in anyone on locals can set whatever
prices they want ours the minimum is
five bucks but we've got people that do
100 bucks a month
some people do five
I've given free memberships to people if
you're if you're a vet or if you were
you know a veteran or if you not a vet
doctor a veteran of a war or if you lost
your job or something like that you know
I'm more than happy to give people some
free access and we built something
really cool so so check it out and I
love the fact that parler is picking up
steam we're in good shape all right
let's see what's going on here
man I've been talking for a while here
we go um let's see so does David Janet
completely spoil you today with
excellent food what's the menu plan or
will he surprise you so I don't know
what the menu plan is yet I haven't
eaten anything except for the coffee
that I'm drinking right in front of me
which has I put a scoop of collagen
protein powder and I do some mushroom
supplements some lion's mane and some
other stuff in there so I haven't eaten
anything today I assume there'll be
something fun planned for lunch and then
dinner as I said we're going out with
friends I can't publicly announce where
we're going but it's one of my favorite
restaurants in in LA and I haven't been
out to eat and and you know whatever it
is for months or something so I am
psyched about that but David is an
incredible chef you can check out his
Instagram it's David's cookbook is the
name of it and you can also go to
David's cookbook comm and see a lot of
the stuff that he's cooking and and he's
working on a cookbook also an actual
cookbook and yeah that you know one of
the nice things about lockdown is that I
hope you learned some skills or refine
something that you do or found some new
hobbies or something like that so one of
the things that I've done is are the
entire side of our house is lined with
planters we built them and then I bought
a couple but lined with planters that
are you know like this and we've got
about I don't know 30 feet of planters
and we're growing tomatoes and peppers
and cucumbers and zucchini I grew a
zucchini that was like this but huge
cucumbers and what else would be growing
back there all sorts of it's like a huge
amount of different peppers and
jalapenos and all kinds of stuff
and I love doing it I love tending to
the it's not a garden per se it's just
you know it's my it's an LA Garden I
guess you could say but I love tending
to it and I love eating the things that
we make and I think a lot of people got
or into gardening or did more house
projects in the midst of this stuff one
of the things that I was saying at the
beginning of lockdown is it's like
there's opportunity here you know it's
like you're stuck in your house it's
like well make your house nicer figure
out some new skills learn a new hobby
whatever it might be and I think a lot
of people actually did do that so that
is nice all right let's see what else is
going on over here were you a gamer what
kind of games did you and do you like to
play so I was a gamer back in the day
which is why I referenced working at
Electronics Boutique I mean my youth was
growing up on I remember seeing 8-bit
Nintendo at my buddy Jon's house for the
first time I think in 85 I was about
nine years old and I remember seeing
Mario Brothers and I was blown away
so Nintendo you know the original
Nintendo which I have my childhood
original Nintendo in the other room it
wasn't working I was blowing in the
games I actually watched a YouTube video
I took it apart I cleaned every little
pieces of it and it's humming like a
bird these days so I've got my original
Nintendo in there I've got Sega Genesis
in there Colin Moriarty gave me a ps4
you may remember that from awhile back
and then a fan sent me a Nintendo switch
but honestly I don't have time to play
anything I just don't
but during lockdown we did get some
headsets and me and David and my brother
and my nephew who is he's about 10 we
play gauntlet Slayer Edition on ps4 so
it's just like it's just a hack slash
you know you got the wizard and the
Valkyrie and the little guy he has the
other thing and you just run around just
crushing things and that's sort of the
limit of what my I can't do these big
role-playing games I can't invest I
don't like running 3d I like sort of
looking down on things and then running
through things it's just how my brain
works at this point so I wish I had more
time I really do like when I walk if I'm
at a mall or something and I walk by a
video game store I always walk in I like
seeing what's going on I just don't I
just know I don't have the time in life
but I was a huge huge gamer Sega Genesis
was probably my my favorite system
that's where I got into all the all the
sports games NBA Live and Madden
football and all that stuff I think
ghouls and ghosts is one of the greatest
video game
video games of all time alright let's
see what else do we have here I'm
plowing through I'm just trying to find
some not political ones
oh wait I'm scrolling the wrong way here
here we go
happy birthday just curious to know if
you ever used to have a particular CD or
cassette tape remember when those were
thing in your collection that you
secretly loved but didn't want anyone to
know you had I love this question this
is gonna be the craziest answer you've
ever heard I had a CD that I did not
know that I did not want people to know
I had back in the day if you bought a
happy meal at McDonald's for like
another dollar or something they had
like eight CDs you could buy and I
remember going to McDonald's near my
house on Jericho Turnpike and buying a
happy meal I got a fish fillet sandwich
with cheese that's it no tartar no
lettuce fish fillet sandwich with cheese
pretty dry I don't know why I liked it
but I did and I got I paid an extra
dollar and I got uh Tina Turner greatest
hits album and I don't know why I didn't
want people I don't know if I thought it
was girly or whatever I didn't want
people to know I had it but I would
listen to Tina Turner's Greatest Hits
you know you're simply the best what's
love got to do with it nutbush City
Limits and I just absolutely loved it I
still love Tina Turner going back to a
question earlier but she just turned 80
man I would love to interview her I
think she lives in Switzerland now I
think she might have even renounced her
US citizenship I would get on a plane
tomorrow if I could sit down with her
you know her story Anna Mae Bullock is
her real name her story is absolutely
incredible and and there was the movie
what's love got to do with it with
Angela Bassett and what's-his-name from
the matrix Laurence Fishburne and you
know that she married Ike Turner and it
was hugely abusive like horrific ly
abusive and drug use and all that stuff
but she she kept going she kept going
she knew what she wanted and she
eventually becomes the the solostar Tina
Turner that we all know so Tina's my
favorite
solo female musician by far I would say
Frankie Valli on the male side I'm old
school what can I tell you guys but I
don't know why I didn't want people to
know it but I do remember old CD I
remember old CDs not old not old CDs old
cassette tapes where you could listen to
something on the radio and then I had
like a Sony boombox and you could record
what was on the radio and create your
own mixes it was a long time ago man a
long time let's see alright it is it is
nice wow I've been going for a while ago
now or 15 alright we'll do a couple more
and then I don't know what these people
have in store for me for my birthday it
could involve anything here in LA I
might be able to take a walk that's
pretty much all you can do it would be a
walk I'm gonna take a birthday walk
alright let's see
Dave I will go back to a political one
for a sec do you think the opposition to
this Cultural Revolution we are now in
can effectively counter the left without
its own activists and protesters on the
streets I think people like Matt Walsh
Chuck Carlson you etc are fighting the
good intellectual fight but is that
enough to stem the tide there's a couple
interesting things about that question I
mean I don't think it can be won purely
on the idea side meaning this is one of
the flaws I see with a lot of people and
I'm sure I fall into this and I would
say a lot of the IDW crew whatever is
left of that falls into you can't just
sit there and criticize the ideas and
think that that's gonna win in and of
itself and I think the reason we know
that to be true is that if criticizing
the ideas was the totality of how you
how you fight this thing then well there
were plenty of us doing this for years
and some of these ideas would have been
stopped right like all of us saying this
stuff about college campuses and calling
it out and all the viral videos that we
all made about it it would have done
something to stop it but but it actually
didn't now that isn't to say that what
we did did nothing because I think it
woke up millions of people in the
process I meet you guys all the time and
you tell me that so that's great too and
that's sort of the silent majority
theory but I think one of the things
that I see now is that a lot of people
are just saying the same things over and
over like oh we were saying those things
three years ago and yes it is I do find
it personally validating that the things
that I was saying five years ago now
every
is saying so I find that it's like oh
that's nice and that's validating but
obviously just saying things just me
talking about these things or other
people talking about these things that
is not enough now these guys are using
violence they're they're tearing down
statues they're burning down cities
every Democrat is afraid to say a word
because they know they'll come for them
right Nancy Pelosi do I think Nancy
Pelosi really wants to take down
pictures of old Democrats in the Senate
or does she really want to take down
statues no but she knows she can't stop
it because they'll gladly destroy her
she's an old right rich millionaire
white woman they'll take her out they'll
take Schumer out they'll gladly take
Biden out and they'll take everybody
else out they have nothing left to stop
it what I do think can stop it I mean in
many ways this is what my books about
the Conservatives have some tools to
stop it that the Liberals don't have
this is I've talked about this but it's
it's a sad thing for me to admit in a
way and I address it in the book that
liberalism and it's in its truest sense
does have a weakness
the idea of liberalism as
open-mindedness and open inquiry and
tolerance and diversity well it can be
so full of tolerance that it becomes
tolerant of intolerance and that's what
the progressives and the Marxist snuck
into the political system to basically
destroy the left in America and to
destroy and eat out and hollow out the
the Democratic Party doesn't you know
it's like the Democrats weren't always
like this they weren't you know when I
talked to my parents about this who were
old-school Democrats it's like JFK
Democrats it wasn't like this there was
a reason a sensible reason to be a
Democrat the left and the progressives
have completely annihilated that from
the inside they basically I think they
realize how Bernie didn't get where we
want him to get let's just burn down the
whole freaking system so I guarantee you
bernie is very happy right now but
Bernie if you're watching you shouldn't
be that happy cuz you're an old
millionaire with three houses too and
they're coming for you buddy because at
the end of the day you'll have supported
by it and you supported Hillary and
you're a sellout and you don't stand for
anything actually but putting that aside
I don't think just talking about these
things can stop it I think the
conservatives and when I say
conservatives now I mean anyone that
believes in individual
if you believe that the Constitution is
a good founding document if you believe
in God given rights and individual
rights that that mean that everyone
that's a legal citizen should have the
same exact rights regardless of their
skin color and all that stuff which is
what we're supposed to believe and what
most of us do believe but the radicals
have tricked us into thinking is somehow
big innit even though they're the ones
that are the new bigots so that's what I
mean by conservative if you are that you
got to start building institutions right
now that's by the way wildin and i said
before about parlor it doesn't matter
whether parlor absolutely is gonna work
or not as the twitter replacement or the
twitter killer but the idea that they're
building something is right the idea
that I took competition and decided to
start a tech company is right
I think locals is going to explode and
save a lot of a lot of good people from
being banned off these things but
ultimately competition freedom all of
these things the the right needs to
start building institutions it needs to
start building academic institutions and
media institutions and journalistic
institutions and and I think some of
them exist and do not let social justice
in there social justice is going to
destroy every liberal institution every
liberal college every mainstream media
outlet the New York Times CNN Harvard
Yale they're all going down there is
nothing that can be done the core is
melting down we can pretend that they
have to stay and that they're worth
fighting for and that isn't to say that
everyone that's part of them is all bad
but the thing is going down and all of
the academics and all of the pundits now
keep talking about it in an intellectual
way you're all going down with it it's
just it's just it just is doesn't mean
it's a great thing it just is people
that are on the right what I would say
are new conservatives and by the way my
my new book or my second book which we
were you just took care of the deal is
gonna be about this conservatives have a
chance to build new institutions that
will be stronger and wiser and
conservatives are not good at the
cultural stuff and they're gonna have to
get on board some of that stuff they're
gonna have to get on board some of the
the new horizons in terms of space and
science and that families may not look
exactly like they wanted families to
look at but they got the big stuff right
about family there's all sorts of
interesting things happening on the
right so yes you cannot fight it just on
the idea about all alone II cannot this
thing cannot be won by great Tucker
Carlson monologues that's not a shot at
Tucker
I love Tucker I think he's doing great
work but it can't just be one with ideas
these people are gonna come to burn down
things then you got to build things and
you got to build them fast and and and
with the right with the right people
behind it and I think that can actually
be done
all right people I'm gonna do two more
and then I'm gonna go take a birthday
walk very exciting let's see this is a
good one and then Michael see if you're
getting or Phoenix see if you can grab
one more is the final one that should be
the perfect final one for me as I answer
this one this is Erik he says what has
been the most humbling moment thought or
realization you've had during the launch
and rise of locals Reuben report calm
don't burn this book and all your other
successes this year I mean the whole
thing like literally the whole thing
I'll try to give you a better answer for
that but like on the broad level every
single day I get a text from somebody
who says you know I'm with a friend
right now and he just mentioned you and
didn't even know we were friends or I'm
with you no I just I'm out working I saw
that somebody has your book there or you
know I was at my friend's house and I
saw his computer was open and your show
was on they're like I get some version
of that text every day from somebody so
that is pretty freaking awesome it's
really really cool you know there's a
there's a guy who I won't mention his
name but he's he lives on my street and
he's a he's a well-known record
executive he's retired now but had had
his hand in major major records of the
last 30 years and one day I was walking
Clyde and he said hey Dave Rubin and
Clyde I saw you on Dana Perino and we
started talking it turns out that we
grew up two blocks he's a little older
than me but we grew up two blocks away
from each other in the same hometown we
went to the same high school somehow
ended up living here together and he's
he's a become a big fan and a good guy
and introduced me to some of the other
neighbors and when you start realizing
that there's other sane people in your
neighborhood this is why what what is
happening right now through the Marxist
or whatever you want to call these guys
I'm tired of talking about as the left
but this new thing what it preys on is
that we will stop talking to each other
that you won't know what your neighbors
think that you will be afraid to share
whatever your your thoughts are and when
you put something out in the world and
then people respond positively to it you
don't know how that can affect things so
that I've been able to be a little bit
of a part of that and then get the
successes along with that you know like
some of the financial successes you know
it's nice to it's nice when people say
nice things about me or I get emails
people will say you know Dave I I you
know one of the type of things that I
get all the time is people will say Dave
you know I've been watching your show
for three months and I didn't realize
you were gay and then you offhand made a
comment about it's like you know I'm a
conservative I'm a Christian I just want
you to know I don't care you know like
you seem like a good guy like I love
hearing things like that even though the
you know HuffPo or box will have you
believe i'm radicalizing people to the
alt-right but you guys are good you're
good so I would say it's sort of like
the whole package you know and I guess
the lesson in that is get over the
bravery deficit you know my last Prager
you video was entitled the bravery
deficit get over it if you think you can
weather this storm this thing that is
happening in our country right now and
it's happening all over Western nations
it's happening in the UK right now all
over the place if you think you can just
be quiet and not say what you think just
so that you'll be spared or that we'll
get through this or someone else will
fix it well then you're gonna get what
you deserve at the end you know and in
the video the bravery deficit you should
check it out on youtube if you haven't
seen it I describe it you're a frog in a
slowly boiling pot and it does not end
well for the frogs so get on board fight
I don't think there's anything
particularly brave or special or
whatever about me I'm some guy who
started talking and it started working
so that is it and that you guys have
been on the adventure for me is or the
adventure with me is amazing
all right I like this one who has been
your biggest influence in comedic
political and intellectual forums
I like this one because it's my birthday
and and at 44 I think I've managed to do
something decent here and and you don't
just do that on your own you do it
because people people help you get there
so in the comedic one you know I
mentioned Cosby earlier but that's not
really the full answer because that was
the one that sort of got me interested
in the whole thing I would say George
Carlin is the greatest stand-up comic
ever
I mean his the the way with words the
linguistic brilliance the societal stuff
you know he got a lot of people don't
know the night that Lenny Bruce got
arrested George Carlin was arrested with
him he fought against censorship he the
breath of his work you know he did
something like 20 HBO specials and his
last HBO special which was I think about
10 years ago I think he died on if I'm
not mistaken he died on June 22nd 2010
something like that maybe it was a
little after that but June 22nd I'm
pretty sure was the day he died his last
HBO special which was just a couple
months before he died he's absolutely
brilliant he had a couple specials
before that that were a little off track
in my opinion but the breath of doing
that many of those specials where you're
saying something that it's true that
it's real man there he was he was just
the best in the comedy world there's
always this debate about about Pryor
verse Carlin that those seemed to be the
big two and I would say you know Pryor
did more stuff about himself it was
about his own pain his own existence all
of that Karlin did more societal stuff
that's that's more interesting to me
personally Pryor was great but Pryor
also i think only had two major specials
where Karlin had had a gajillion of them
so that's the comedic the political on
the political side who has influenced me
the most on the political side who is
influenced me the most I mean I never
met him but I would say John Stuart Mill
on Liberty I mentioned this all the time
I've got a copy of it in my nightstand
you can read it it's like this thick you
can get through it it is worth reading
about understanding where rights come
from and what the role of government
be and what your duty as the citizen is
and all of those things I would have
loved to have interviewed him apparently
it's not gonna happen maybe maybe we
could do some Jurassic Park style
cloning one of these days you know in a
modern sense I don't know that there's
anyone there are politicians that I like
like I like Rand Paul but I don't know
that there's anyone that has influenced
me in a huge way it's more about the
thinkers before who set this you know
it's all about those patriarchal those
white supremacist thinkers like George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson I mean
Thomas Jefferson really go to his house
in Virginia
Monticello go there before they burn
that thing down and by the way you take
the tour there 80% of the tour is
talking about slavery
so they imply though they're like I'm
trying to hide history the guy was
writing the laws that freed the slaves
and was a better person than any of you
idiots that are taking his monuments
down and then on the intellectual forum
I mean it's Jordan for sure right like I
spent a year and a half on the road with
Jordan Peterson in 20 countries and over
a hundred shows and and I got to be
around the the most important public
intellectual of our time who I promise
you will be back hopefully sometime this
year I I don't want to end too much but
I have a sense you may hear something
from him kind of soon but to see that
this guy fought for what he believed and
stood up to every mob that went after
him made people's lives better the
people at the shows who I crying they
were off drugs they got out of abusive
relationships they stopped being abusive
they fixed whatever family problems they
had I saw this guy fixed the world
genuinely fixed the world and I saw him
on the intellectual side I would he
never gave the same talk twice an hour
and a half lecture one night he would be
doing with this thing and then I could
see he would get to a point where and
sometimes he would say it he would say
you know you would do something like
this he would go you know I need to I
need to think about that a little bit
more and I'm gonna continue on that and
then literally the next night I would
see him start going there and then he
would push it a little bit for
I don't know what kind of public
intellectual what kind of performer does
that sort of thing like takes those kind
of risks but he did it he did it every
night and you know if you haven't read
my book yet Chapter nine it's all about
what it was like to be on the road with
Jordan and and he sort of became a
mentor by osmosis and yeah that that is
all I've got to say about that
all right people I've been talking for
one hour and 32 minutes I believe we
were trying to get this to an hour 30
that's pretty good thank you guys for
all the kind words I'm seeing all oh and
Joe Jorgenson just emailed confirming
our interview all right Joe even the
Libertarians is disorganized as they
might be apparently they know how to get
on YouTube happy to see it thank you
guys for all the birthday wishes all the
support it's been a great year this is
just the beginning I'm probably gonna be
pretty quiet on social media today I'll
jump in over at Rubin reports calm
probably do a live chat post some posts
and personal stuff but I think I'm gonna
ease up on on Twitter for my birthday
and now I'm going to take a birthday
walk which is one of the only two legal
things you can do here in California
you're allowed to take a walk and you
are allowed to go to the bathroom
between 3:00 and 4:00 p.m. Pacific thank
you guys have a great day everybody
I need some water
[Music]